this is the very first question I showed
you before on which I argued you've been
using these inverse trig functions for a
while you're used to them what's the big
deal okay now can you rehearse for me
again what was the working yard that we
showed what would be the very first line
if we're trying to find theta in this
case I've actually got rid one side so I
think I used signed in there I said sign
equals this okay now usually you would
go straight to your calculator but we
included a line of working to clarify
what was going on what was the next line
equals okay and then you get your
calculator and it's fine okay but this
an unspoken assumption going on here you
remember I said before you've learnt all
this new stuff we need to account for
but they're also nuances in what's going
on here that we have ignored okay you
have all assumed fair enough because
you've been told to but to go from here
to here what has happened what have you
done to both sides you have taken sine
inverse of both sides right you're
assuming this
now that is a reasonable assumption to
make okay because in all of the
equations you've been working with so
far you have learned if you do something
to the left-hand side you do it to the
right-hand side and everything will be
okay right
except there's a problem okay
is this really true is this really true
I want you to think about the way that
we've defined sine inverse and this line
and why there is a problem this is very
very tricky okay let's just try some
values out I actually want you to get
your calculator out with me and just see
what happens
calculator this is what I'm trying to
test just sine inverse of sine theta
does it really equal theta okay yeah we
talked about kinds of proof before we
were looking induction right I'm gonna
be a little scientific here okay I'm
just going to experiment and I'm gonna
repeat some observations so for instance
let's have a go at well this one's a bit
meaningless
let's try one which is simple let's go
to sine inverse of sine 0 now if we're
following this pattern you should expect
0 right
make sure you're in actually doesn't
matter
put it radians just in case but when you
put in sine inverse of sine 0 what do
you get okay so far so good
okay let's try another angle okay I
think from memory this is 37 degrees
sine inverse of sine 37 degrees what do
you get
oh I just told you to put it in radians
danaka that'd be better be like zero
point I don't know 6 or 7 or something
like that what do you get
yeah sorry I put 0.16 right did you get
that back okay so far so good let's try
another angle let's go let's go a little
bigger this time let's go say I don't
know play on to sign a message side PI
on to what do you get you get one point
five seven bummer why'd you get planted
no problems okay let's just this is key
guy sine inverse let's try an angle like
PI because I know what sine pi is right
what is your calculator tell you hold on
just check it maybe you're doing your
calculator wrong because you don't I do
i do sometimes we don't busy rolling you
be careful with your brackets all that
are you sure hmm so you know this
Mythbusters right
I call that busted except the back part
busted isn't it because it seems to work
sometimes it breaks that here is this
the only place it breaks come on let's
be scientific let's try something else
give me another angle supply
what do you get you get zero huh let's
try a more interesting angle let's try
say 3.2 because that's a little less
boring than pilots you pine what do you
get
what do you get you get negative 1 point
5 7 which is negative pilot - now hold
on what's going on ok it's not like it
works it works it works and then it just
gives you zero right it works it works
and then it gives you weird stuff what's
going on right and you work out what's
going on
so this is why I had to leave this on
the board okay
what's the domain of sign what's not not
a trick question what's the domain of
site it's well regular signage goes
forever right so I can stick anything I
like in here doesn't matter how big how
small and it will accept it okay
but when sign inverse gives you back an
odd cell right it is restricted right so
no matter what angle you're sticking
here you will only ever get something
between - plan - Thank You Podrick and
plan - that's what all of these fit
right that's as far as you can go that
far that far right so Sonia verse of
Scythia doesn't always equal theta where
does it equal theta
it only equals theta in this place that
we've respected it because we restricted
it right so therefore this is true for
this which is why whoops this is a
nuance which we could have safely
ignored for questions like this can you
see why you can ignore it because I'm in
a right angle triangle a right angle
triangle so whatever these two angles
are they must be acute and that's why
you as a year Valley could ignore this
right but you're not unite anymore okay
now there's a restriction on that let me
pose the next obvious question to you
we've just said you kind of just do sine
inverse of sine and just expect it to
work out okay
well these are inverse functions right
they reverse each other they should be
mutually invest right
would you expect to make of that you
think about it some of you may actually
well know the answer as to which my
question to you would be
can you explain why we've just explained
why this has a restriction on it does
this work does it work all the time
does it not if not why not and if so
where okay what's it equal to and how
can you argue it okay now